calcul
pour ce soir
j'ai je les
ai perdus je suis comme si j'étais pour l'
hélicoptère de retour dans tout ce temps carré
nous prenons leurs chasseurs tous prêts ouais ouais
plutôt bien
un peu le
déplaçons notre pièce vérifie-le nous avons
le trafic  à venir je suis juste
quel est le spectacle déjà un écho et comme
le serveur principal, vérifiez les flops du petit-déjeuner
oh chéri les chuchotements se transforment en alors
vous
pouvez nous continuer sur cette route cette
rue qui celle-
ci se divise directement pour avoir l'air sympa  ouais
et ensuite nous pourrons rentrer à la maison
probablement un trafic en bas maintenant ça a l'air
vraiment sympa
peut-être deux alors ça finira
peut-être et recommencer et peut-être zoomer
un peu plus nous finissons votre fils d'abord
ouvert jusqu'au parc d'accord  et nous le
ferons une autre fois mais avec un
cadre de valeur différent eh bien vous pouvez faire demi-tour
parce que maintenant il n'y a plus il n'y a plus
rien sur les routes tout le monde va bien
j'arrive au sol ouais et tu zoomes un
peu ils me laissent sortir te faire sortir de  le
parc avec lui-même à d'accord non non o  h bien
si tu veux tu préfères j'ai pris la maison
comme savoir maintenant pourquoi mentiraient-ils p je
pense que la lumière assez loin à notre ouest
que je veux